révolutionnaire après qu'elle en faire
leur nouveau 33 ces religions gros sons
chez les bretons plus jamais couple mais
encore duo voici donc monsieur et madame
niagara muriel et daniel à muriel
boutoir payé le bon soir on n'est pas là
pour rigoler d'étape de 33 tours qui
s'appelle religion pourquoi religion est
subitement tombé comme ça dans une
extase
division gérant contre les garçons quand
j'irai way et puis en fait c'est parce
que je pense qu'en cette fin 2-2
henner 3,10 on approche du 3è de l'unr
je pense qu'on est mystique et peut pas
l'ignorer et je pense que la ligne 8
c'est pas normal problème de savoir si
on croit en outre attendu ans qui se
comporte en surimpression du kiosque
l'homme faveur du ca dire pour moi je me
suis senti concerné par le requiem de
mozart qui est partie visible voilà un
nom ma joie on peut aimer cathédrale est
way
moi je crois qu'on y avait longtemps une
et quatre pattes et non plus moi je
crois pas un mot je tiens à préciser que
moi je crois pas en dieu je veux rien a
priori non plus
bigs moi je crois que j'ai arrêté de
croire en dieu un jour que je faisais du
ski ouais je vais avoir 12 ans comme ça
et je n'arrêtais pas de tomber et je me
suis dit si ce coup ci je tombe encore
c'est que dieu n'existe pas j'ai tombé
trois avions et ça fait des disques qui
s'appelle religion alors qui a fait quoi
l'on ne dise par le soyons concrets
avant tout là encore plus que d'habitude
encore plus que d'habitude
j'aime bien
l'écriture des morceaux quand même
l'écriture des textes les arrangements
sétois vrais problèmes d'adduction ces
moines c'est toi ouais
je pense que l'essentiel c'est les
chansons ouais c'est à dire une mélodie
structure d'accord et un texte l effet
un match as well as
et entreront commence à val
d'or on a passé la mi contraire
indiquant son
nom mais comment ça va
parce que j'ai lu dans la wii c'est le
quart d'heure chez lui dans la presse
vous aviez pris un appartement chacun
vous avez les moyens vous voyez toujours
quand même
mais toujours
c'est autre chose
les fans à l'ehpad kleenex pour les
familles qui
regarde bon alors vous êtes prêts là
maintenant enfin une interview coq à
l'âne va chier c'est à chier
m
l'insultent qui vous a fait le plus mal
quand j'avais 4 ans ouais
c'est la première fois que j'entendais
un truc agressive ouais on a dû lui dire
pour un cumul genre indique si hélas est
révolté la première fois que que que
quelqu'un était méchant est moi ouais
monde vont jusqu'à cet âge là tout le
monde a été gentil mais tu as découvert
la voile à saadiya qui vous envoie la
première fois il se rend compte de la
misère
est pour toi est ce que tu as déjà pensé
au suicide j'espère que c'est pas à ce
moment là mais ouais j'y pense tout le
temps c'est pourquoi tu piges
peut-être pas le courage du peuple
courageux puis les rêves musique c'est
un palliatif mais c'est vrai qu'ils
posent depuis depuis l'âge de 13 14 août
à la fois accepté le revers de la
médaille ouais mais bon d'un autre côté
au départ je croyais que c'était plutôt
une question d'adolescents ouais et puis
ça dure ça guérit pas bien tous
connaissent un petit peu
alors maintenant c'est là les six élèves
et pour toi la suivante tout comme je
suis
un pincement sexisme en réponse
difficile
et nous on a fait la drogue et le
méchant questa de plus sexy on doit
donner le silence
qu'est ce qui faisait le plus
indispensable pour vous endormir
sûrement pas au dernier risque parce que
nos briques et clp
moi je dors très mal de toute façon m
est indispensable
gorman tu penses la voilà cinq ans vers
cette histoire le tract
ça t'as pas le droit jusqu'ici retomber
dans les romains
alors quelque chose négative qui dirait
surtout à ne rien
pour lui a dit d'y aller
je pense que je me dis ah bon
non je pense que j'ai demandé musiciens
parce que je pense de lui l'idéal pour
une étrave
on y voit la question est
celle c'est ici un tout petit peu plus
qu'autre chose mais c'est pas tellement
plus alors dans la rue dans la rue de
même idéal ouais 10 h 30 à cause de paul
mccartney
étoiles sur 5 0 samedi bits et plus en
jambes ainsi la rue l'autre celoni le
vieux ou par contre est incapable de
faire l'amour
ah bon tu veux être vraiment un bras
à bord non moi je suis moi même
cimetière non et toi je crois pas il n'y
a pas d'endroit où
la maison abandonnée avant d'être un
truc en tête ouais non je cause n'y a
pas d'endroit désagréable quand tu as
pleuré pour la dernière fois
ah bon pourquoi
tu dis ça à la télé quant à prétendre à
décrocher le téléphone le signe
avant-coureur de la passion naissante
et de la passion qui s'éteint
je pense que c'est quand les manies des
autres
deux générations pour famille je pense
que ces moments où par exemple
le bruit qui ont touché la bouche en
mangeant pas mon truc les petites routes
là deviennent presque et un sentiment de
claustrophobie là je pense que c'est le
début de la france dont le dernier
soubresaut de la bête quelle est la
question dans toutes celles de plus tous
les autres que les autres vous les posez
vous avez plus à inciter à mentir je
n'ai pas en moins de croiser des centres
-
un peu alors c'est quoi le dis le nous à
[Musique]
j'exagère
parce que un peu trop voilà je pense que
je tâche est pas au niveau des gens donc
je suis constamment en porte à faux et
je me retrouve un peu de fumée c'est
pour ça que nous venons pas bien oui
mais j'ai une transe pendant quelque
temps le malawi ont dit ça quand on a
réussi et toi tu
sais pas menti t'as pas m'en dit non au
chef dur
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu